ce soir est une soirée magique
je vais choisir le chat qui méritent une
deuxième vie aller au bal pourrait
s'avérer dangereux reste pas là
mais on danse je juge les shaks selon la
ram mais mammeri et virtuose
projecteurs et roulements de tambour
s'il vous plaît
que la fête commence
[Musique]
le chat le plus méritant pourra renaître
dans une nouvelle vie
il pourra devenir ce qu'il a toujours
rêvé d'être
ton nom c'est quoi tu dans ta langue au
chat
san martin parr
[Musique]
oh
t'as jamais vu un chat enragé
[Musique]
l'heure est venue de procéder au choix
franchement tu crois que ça va
fonctionner là c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire je crois c'est commencer
[Musique]
j'adore